brace yourselves America and get ready
for the return of the most authoritative
voice in all of news
hello it's the show everyone's talking
about The Wall Street Journal says it
makes people dumb be honest do you
really disagree with that Donald Trump
calls it very boring meal I want to push
back on that but I have been bored by
this show John Oliver has been called a
comedian fool and more unpleasant than a
diuretic and Shearer says he has a wee
red face share said that share said that
don't miss the long-awaited series
return they share we're talking about
the actual share not one of there's only
one share right last week tonight with
John Oliver back despite popular demand
is it going faster what watch our show
something I see that's too quick last
week tonight with John Oliver Sunday's
leveling p.m. HBO yeah